another story lost in the media racists
frenzy Donald Trump introduced the plan
to tighten Asylum rules at the southern
border boiled-down
with some exceptions migrants who pass
through another country first must seek
asylum there rather than at our border
so basically you can't just say to El
Salvador get me out of here when what
you really meant was get me a job in
Phoenix so Trump's plan is simple and
sensible and we've said it before if
you're on the run from something bad why
skip the first safe harbor to use a
movie analogy if Freddy Krueger's on
your tail the first house with the
lights on is the door you're gonna knock
on but I am oversimplifying because
that's what I do
by bringing a safe place closer to a
migrant this change is meant to prevent
suffering by shortening the journey so
you think the Dems would be on board but
no it's Trump now his idea of making
refugees seek asylum in the first safe
nation they came to is one most
countries use and for good reason it
saves lives as the Germans discovered
when Merkel led in millions of refugees
who were told they could go anywhere
they wanted in the EU and many said
London so Britain said auf wiedersehen
to the EU and Merkel's been trying to
walk back her decision ever since Trump
knows Anarchy comes when you're when you
base your laws on political pandering
and what plays well on the view the
caravans were our version of Merkel's
mistake but this reform says not so fast
which is why in all likelihood the
Democrats will hate it all right wine I
want to play a SOT from one Democrat who
seems to agree with this plan let's roll
it
refugee status is not granted just based
on
economic needs or because a family lives
in a bad neighborhood or poverty it's
typically defined fairly narrowly or
maybe some narrow circumstances in which
there is a humanitarian or refugee
status that a family might be eligible
if that were the case would be better
for them to be able to apply in country
rather than take a very dangerous
journey all the way up to Texas well I
really miss his exciting speeches what
you hate President Obama and why I'm
glad you played that side not because he
was so pedantic that's great I guess he
was kind of slow there but but because I
think that there's an opportunity for us
to agree right and to say hey you know
what Congress and the American people
should get together and we need to
change the asylum law to make it more
consistent right yeah the problem is
that the president Trump now has acted
in terms of an executive order executive
action right and I remember when people
would get upset with Obama for taking
that kind of exact issue in executive
orders to take so what we've got now is
the Republicans had two years of total
control of everything the house the
Senate the White House did they change
the asylum law I don't think so but now
they're willing to exploit it it seems
to me for political gain because he
doesn't get the wall he didn't have the
raids over the weekend he didn't get the
question on the census and so now he's
doing this Kennedy you want to respond
tell you're in and that's what happens
whenever one party has all the power the
same thing Democrats completely screwed
up healthcare we're still paying the
price for the failure of Obama care when
they really should have tackled the
immigration because we've learned
unfortunately it's not a bipartisan
issue no party is going to do it
effectively no party really wants to do
it and that's why I think you're seeing
so much distraction between Nancy Pelosi
in the squad and the president and the
squad is because it allows people to not
work on immigration because they really
really don't want to do it and it's so
incredibly
unfortunate because we have to define
these things even when it's painful even
when it's not politically convenient and
you don't score instant points because
sometimes fixes aren't emotional issues
but we have to define what it means to
be a refugee and an SI Li and if there
is such a thing as economic asylum in
this country which that's what a lot of
this boils down to I think Emily right
just say yes yes the reality is we're
not dealing under normal circumstances
right now the average immigration court
case is seven hundred and twenty seven
days for it to be resolved that's over
two years and so we need to triage and
the existing law right now is so
convoluted right we see in the lawsuit
that was filed against the
administration against that executive
order it basically says okay so right
now we have exceptions already for those
that have gone through safe countries
except how is that defined it's
technically only with Canada
it's a multilateral or bilateral or
bilateral agreement is it necessary for
the immigrant to have resettled in that
country or is passing through enough are
we creating a compact with regional a
regional compact with the South or
Central American countries like all of
these questions are up in the air and
what they require is diplomacy and
international relations and attention by
our politicians and elected officials
rather than just the squabbling and the
freaking out that most people are doing
on the left and wasting everyone's time
with frankly these lawsuits but the
bottom line is triage needs to occur
which is what the president was doing by
that executive order and the content of
it already exists in our existing law so
if people have a problem with it they
should be writing their Senators okay
but they're trying to change the laws in
Mexico and Guatemala and the
Legislature's there are not allowing
them to do it so we're not going to have
third safe country agreements with those
two countries any time soon well I'm
just glad Juan finally agrees that Nancy
has to get together with the president
and close the asylum oh I wish I wish
that were my gun class ed that because
the president just a few weeks ago gave
her breathing room and said I'm gonna
hold back on the ice raids for a little
bit if you guys could get your act
together on the asylum deal and she did
nothing so then she went on her July 4th
break and came back and has still got
nothing so it seems to me they don't
want to fix the problem they didn't want
to fix it in December when they were
warned about it and they don't want to
fix it now when you're getting record
people coming across
if you look at what happened in brexit
that's the exact result of the migration
crisis from the you keep migration
crisis that started under obama when all
hell broke loose in syria now get
extended to the election of trump sure
brexit and then because they're all kind
of from bachelor so learn the lesson
look that they had a lot of crime that
terrorism they had the rise of these
right-wing nationalist groups over there
and you have brexit ever as a result so
it seems to me i don't think they really
want to stop the border crisis alright
true by the way realist why haven't they
done anything at a lot of